[Music]
with inflation at a new record high
people need some extra cash and there
are plenty of ways to supplement your
income here are some of those in today's
eight on your side
summertime is the perfect chance for
family vacations and for you to make a
little extra cash when others head out
of town consumer savings expert andrea
warwick says if you've got a backyard
you can be a pet sitter check out
rover.com you can make up to a thousand
dollars a month by watching someone's
dog or cat in your own home especially
smart for someone who works from home if
you're home all day
why not watch a dog at the same time and
make that extra cash you can rent your
backyard pool by the hour on the
swimpley app which also comes with an
insurance policy for families whose kids
have outgrown the baby and toddler stage
instead of selling those items rent them
out to people who are on vacation in
your area there are parents out there
who travel who don't want to carry bulky
baby items with them so high chairs
cribs strollers
play mats and play centers these are
things you can rent by the day through
babyquip.com and that could become a
nice extra income for yourself the
roadie app lets you earn money whether
you are driving local or long haul
you can also get paid to help people
build items through the taskrabbit app
and while everyone knows they can rent
out their spare bedroom or the entire
home on sites like vrbo or airbnb
warwick also suggests the following you
can rent your car by the hour through
getaround.com that program does include
insurance so you don't have to worry
about that easy way to make some extra
cash or maybe offset some of those auto
maintenance costs
and if you have professional skills and
want to freelance by the hour you can
sign up for that at upwork